well rescuers have been searching
through rubble in the czech republic
after a tornado left a trail of
destruction through the country's
southeast
at least three people were killed and
dozens injured when the storm tore
through several towns and villages
neighboring austria and slovakia have
sent crews to join the rescue effort
the storm knocked out power to thousands
of households now
tornadoes are a rare occurrence in the
region
let's get an update on the story with
ian willoughby he's a journalist with
radio prague
international ian thanks for joining us
we were just looking at some really
dramatic pictures there and there are
eyewitness accounts of the moment that
the storm struck
can you describe those to us well it's
really like something from a hollywood
disaster movie what they've seen in that
area
south moravia people have spoken about
cars flying through the air in the
tornado
and today there are many images of
damaged cars some of them sticking up in
the air at impossible angles
also many buildings were badly damaged
with windows blown out
roofs blown off trees ripped up and also
power lines
this tornado is being described as the
worst ever
in modern czech history but also i
should say it wasn't just
the tornado there were also huge hail
stones
some of them the size of tennis balls
and they also did a lot of damage
ian is the rescue operation still
ongoing
oh yes it is to me uh present more than
a hundred teams of rescue workers
are searching through the rubble of
buildings and through damaged buildings
looking for survivors they're using
sniffer dogs
and special equipment the latest figure
as you said is that three people are
known to have been killed in this
disaster
but looking at the the uh extent of the
destruction it's hard to imagine
that figure wouldn't rise during the day
the authorities are saying hundreds of
people have been damaged
hundreds of people have been injured in
this disaster
and at present tens of thousands of
homes are without power
yeah we've just been looking at some
images of that destruction ian
we mentioned that tornadoes are a rare
sight in these parts tell us more about
that
well they're extremely rare the tornado
we saw here yesterday in the czech
republic
was the kind of thing the kind of
twister people might more expect to see
somewhere like arizona in the united
states
but tornadoes of this kind aren't only
unusual
in this region in central europe they're
unusual in the whole of europe
apparently
in the last two decades they've only
been a couple of dozen
tornadoes of this force in europe and
the last
major tornado here in the czech republic
occurred in 2004
so a full 17 years ago
and ian just quickly are they gonna have
to appeal for for aid for this uh
cleanup operation
well the czech government is already
committing uh aid to help
the regions that are affected also there
has been aid from other countries these
slovaks and
uh austrians have sent
ambulances and rescue helicopters and
it's a really big operation
also what we've seen today is that there
have been several
uh public like charity collections to
help those who have been
impacted by this natural disaster
journalist ian willoughby speaking to us
uh thank you so much for that update